enfin sujet tu as l'air c'est de la
fausse et l'intox à ces l'écologie
l'effet de serre vous connaissez
certains gaz peu lors laissent passer
les rayons du soleil mais empêche la
chaleur de s'évacuer vers la haute
atmosphère
résultat la terre se réchauffe
principaux responsables gaz carbonique
et les chlorofluorocarbones mais il y en
a un bien moins connu le méthane exhalé
par les bovins ou plus simplement leurs
hôtes vache c'est tout problème la
digestion le l'herbe par les ruminants
cette digestion est faite par des
fermentations y elle-même dégage du
méthane en quantité importante
mais face à sa façon c'est un atout que
soient le fait d'ailleurs si le tube est
bouché il arrive même par une autre
option quelconque une pomme ou un truc
comme ça
il arrive ça les fait éclater selon une
étude américaine les éruptions de bovins
seraient responsables de 15 % des rejets
de méthane et chacun sait que le méthane
est moins présent dans la basse
atmosphère que le gaz carbonique mais il
est soixante trois fois plus polluant un
bovin contribuerez au temps à l'effet de
serre que les deux tiers de toutes les
pollutions que nous rejetons en
utilisant l'énergie fossile
c'est à dire les combustibles et les
carburants n'empêche que il ya toujours
eu des animaux sur la terre et je pense
que la terre portera des animaux encore
longtemps
on s'active à lui pour lui on peut se
poser la question de savoir si c'est pas
encore un procédé pour essayer d'imposer
sur les vaches une taxe anti pollution
[Musique]
est ce qu'on pourrait pas essayer de
mettre au rachat masques à gaz qui
neutraliserait le gaz et qui ne polluera
pour l'atmosphère et le pet de vache me
direz vous eh bien rassurez-vous le pet
de vache lui n'est pas polluant ou alors
est de la prouesse de l'intox
agnès à l'oreille l'hérault de vaches
sont ils en partie responsable de
l'effet de faire
cloclo à toi de jouer alors je trouve
que c'est de l'intox
tu penses que c'est de l'intox dans sa
peau lui moi je dire moi je dirais que
ça pollue les
les ports aussi peu loin un peu lu
beaucoup il ya trop d'élevage d'animaux
et on laisse pas assez reposé la terre
et même les animaux sont au plus bas par
leurs excréments
c'est absolument dégueulasse tout
simplement
des antibiotiques jury dauphin l'étoile
bleue c'est de l'info limpide
moi je pense que c'est plutôt de l'info
de la faut que tu m'as dit que c'était
de l'intox
moi je dis que c'est de l'intox aussi un
peu exagéré je pense que la guerre du
golfe pollue un tout petit peu plus dans
mon avis les familles incorrect parce
que c'est plus dur que les cours la la
la la photo
synthèse comme on s'appelle de la meyrin
ge c'est une cata personne en parle ça
hier on s'est un petit peu déchiré pour
nos quatre bidons d'huile et de pétrole
tout le monde est content tu me crois
que c'est terminé voilà maintenant on
parle beaucoup de cas rémy jane théâtre
je t'aime
enfin toute belle c'est un peu alors là
écoutez on va savoir si c'est de l'info
ou de l'intox on m'écoute notre expert
et bien bravo claude désole claude
puisque c'est de l'info à on applaudit
clos l'enquêté mi temps
à gauche paris
ça va qu'il fallait s'excuser quand on
repère enfin là bon ben ça alors
philippe tu as un commentaire là dessus
oui diriger un commentaire puisque une
très sérieuse étude américaine qui a
coûté près de deux cent dix mille
dollars je sais c'est pas grand chose
mais c'est déjà ça prouve qu'aujourd'hui
les vaches dégage 15% du méthane présent
dans l'atmosphère
les végétariens eux prétendent avoir
trouvé la solution ne mangeons pas de
viande mais ma chère agnès mon cher
thierry mais cher claude mon public tant
aimé je vous pose une question
croyez-vous qu'un rôle de végétariens ne
dégage pas de méthane et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu